كوي الى السيطره على هذا المكان لم ولن
يكون بالامر السهل وهنا فتحت ابواب
الاقتراع واغلقت امام المصوتين في
الانتخابات النصفيه
داخل صناديقها وخارجها دارت منافسه حاميه
بين فريقي الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فايزه
في البيت الابيض قد تبدو تلك الاشارات
المبكره للديمقراطيين افضل مما هو متوقع
ما دفع زبيد موردا بصوره مبتسمه مهنئا
للفائزين من حزبه
اما هنا فقد خسر حزب الرئيس قد تنقلب
الطاوله ويصدق استطلاقه
لاراء الناخبين لدى خروجهم من مراكز
الاقتراع في الانتخابات النصفيه بالولايات
المتحده حيث اظهر الاستطلاع ان نحو سبعه
من كل عشره من المقترعين لا يعيدون ترشح
الرئيس جوبيد لولايه لرئاسيه ثانيه لكن في
الوقت نفسه اعرب نحو سته من كل عشره عن
راي سلبي بشان الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بين ريال الديمقراطيين وتطلع الجمهوريين
تبقى الموجه الحمراء قيد الانتظار لتحدد
ملامح اداء رئيس البلاد خلال الفتره
المقبله في انتظار ما تبقى من نتائج عصام
عبد السلام العربيه